هذا وقال رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
ان قطر تسلمت ردا من حركه حماس بشان
الاتفاق الاطار واكد في مؤتمر صحفي جمعه
بوزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن في
العاصمه القطريه الدوحه اكد ان الاتفاق
يتضمن ملاحظات وانه يبعث على التفاؤل وشدد
على عدم الخوض في التفاصيل الان لحساسيه
المرحله وفق
تعبيره
استلمنا ردا من حركه حماس بشان الاطار
العام لاتفاقيه الاطراف بشان ما يخص
الرهان يتضمن الرد بعض الملاحظات على
الاطار ولكن في مجمله رد ايجابي على
الاطار ولكن نظرا
لحساسيه هذه المرحله لا يمكننا الخوف
التفاصيل
ويدعون هذا الرد للتفائل وتم تسليم الر
للجانب الاسرائيلي ولقد حذرنا ايضا منذ
اليوم الاول من اندلاع مواجهات من اندلاع
المواجهات يعني من مخاطر اتساع دائره
العنف في المنطقه وحيث ان المنطقه ايضا
تعاني من ازمات
ونزاعات مستمره ومزمن ويؤسفنا يحزن ان نرى
هذه المخاوف تصبح واقعا لنا اليوم وهذا
الامر يزيد الوضع تعقيدا ويعرض المفاوضات
القائمه لوصول ل هدنه في قطاع غزه الى
خطر كما دعا رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
دع المجتمع الدولي لتحمل المسؤوليه بفرض
وقف فوري لاطلاق النار في غزه ونوه في
معرض حديثه ان وقف الدعم عن وكاله الامم
المتحده لغوث وتشغيل اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
الاونور ستكون له تداعيات انسانيه
كارثيه ندعو المجتمع الدولي لتحمل
المسؤوليه فرض وقف فوري لاطلاق النار فقد
ان الاوان لموقف دولي حازم ضد هذه الحرب
المدمره وضد اي اجراء من شانه يوسع دائره
العنف كما اود في هذا السياق ان انوه بان
وقف الدعم عن وكاله الامم المتحده لاغاثه
تشغيل اللاجئين فلسطينيين ستكون له
تداعيات كارثيه حيث سيحرم اكثر من 6
ملايين شخص فلسطيني من الخدمات الاغاثه
والانسانيه ونحن نؤمن باهميه الامم
المتحده وباهم الاونور ودورها ويجب عل
الفصل بين الوكاله كمؤسسه امميه ذات قيم
وتقاليد راسخه وبين التهم التي طالت عدد
من موظفينها الذين يخضعون للتحقيق ولا
نستطيع ان نعاقب وكاله انسانيه كامله بسبب
اتهامات تطال بعض
موظفيها